et pour en parler avec nous sur ce
plateau jacques naisy politologue à
l'université des antilles bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors expliquez nous un peu
comment expliquer ce regain de tension
est ce que la participation des
policiers peut changer la donne et est
ce que les manifestants peuvent enfin
obtenir gain de cause
d'autres jeux il faut dire que haïti est
traversée par une crise structurelle
assez profonde et que l'affrontement
aujourd'hui entre policiers et
militaires est l'expression d'une
société en crise traversée de part en
part par une forte demande sociale alors
les policiers sont dans la société sont
au coeur de la société haïtienne
automobile leurs revendications sont
greffées sur sur celles exprimées par la
population depuis bientôt trois ans ou
même deux ans est ce que il ya eu un
ensemble de manifestations par exemple
l'année dernière le pays était
complètement fermée
est ce que les haïtiens appelle le
pilote comme pays fermé complètement où
ils demandaient non seulement la
démission du président joël moïse mais
également un changement complet de
systèmes c'est à dire que qu'il faudrait
annoncer une rupture avec les pratiques
mafieuses de la gestion de l'état et
aussi avec cette politique de captation
d'un os de l'étape à une petite élite
qui est en connivence avec le pouvoir
politique et cette élite et quoique
privé d'origine privée mais elle est
essentiellement un caractérisée par des
liens de dépendance et qui tentent de
soumettre le pouvoir exécutif à leur
allégeance ce qui fait troisième élément
le président joël moïse n'a pas les
moyens de sa politique il a mené une
campagne où il a promis aux haïtiens de
changer leurs conditions de vie mais il
arrive qu'il n'a pas eu les moyens pour
financer sa politique ses promesses ne
sont pas couronnées de succès de ce qui
entraîne un océan de frustration et donc
les policiers et donc on demandé
au gouvernement de prendre en compte les
revendications revendications qu'il faut
le souligner et c'est un corps de police
frappé par le dénuement total des
salaires assez faible et puis dans des
conditions de travail exécrables
alors ils ont demandé ces policiers qui
se réunissent un syndicat la
constitution n'autorise autorise chacun
chaque corps social à s'organiser en
syndicats leleu la direction générale de
la police nationale n'attend plus
parlante a pas parlé refuse tout
compromis à cette demande de ces dit
qu'il ya de formation de syndicats de ce
qui entraîne la révocation d'un certain
nombre de policiers soit cinq leaders du
mouvement syndical alors ils demandent
la réintégration de ces justement elle
et les policiers certains policiers
dénoncent des licenciements injustifiés
est-ce que ça c'est crédible est avérée
et bien c'est un problème de norme
disant que la constitution autorise les
policiers à champagny d'un syndicat mais
il ya un décret qui ferme toutes les
portes à cette possibilité
deux des policiers de ceux réunis en
syndicat
donc ce qui crée une tension dire entre
lier au sein de la hiérarchie des normes
entre la constitution et ce décret alors
il arrive qu aujourd'hui le président de
la république après avoir concerté avec
le directeur de la police nationale
souhaite maintenant l'organisent la
formation d'une commission b on peut le
dire que les problèmes on les
connaissait depuis longtemps en bus ce
code police a été cueilli après la
dissolution de l'armée en 1994 avec le
soutien de la communauté internationale
notamment des états unis d'amérique mais
il arrive que ce corps de police est
complètement très souvent
installés dans des conditions exécrables
est ce que vous voyez une sortie de
crise
comment est-ce qu'on peut envisager une
sortie de crise est ce que la
participation des policiers à ce
mouvement est bien peu peut aboutir à
une sortie de crise rapide
disons que lorsque sam est quand même
plus de pression sur les gouvernements
ici c'est une tension supplémentaire pl
manifestants oui c'est une tâche
supplémentaire on va dire et puisque
c'est il y à une crise de décomposition
de l'état un état qui n'arrivent plus à
assumer ses responsabilités c'est-à-dire
garantie de la sécurité l'ordre public
c'est une crise aussi de dépossession de
l'état parce que au sein même de
l'appareil de l'état
certains expliquent qu'il y à une
connivence entre les hauts
fonctionnaires et des groupes de gangs
armés et que les groupes de gangs armés
sont aussi à la solde de certains hommes
politiques qui pour des raisons
électoralistes occupent l'espace les
bidonvilles notamment où ces chefs de
gangs sont rémunérés par des hommes
politiques
alors il y à une crise aussi de
défaillance du président de la
république qui n'arrivent plus à assumer
ses responsabilités et d'ailleurs il
avait ce qu'on peut envisager une
démission du président haïtien
mais justement c'est ce qu'on demande
depuis tantôt un an le président ne
semble pas fermée mais à chaque fois ils
avancent d'un pas de l'autre ils
reculent par exemple à il dit oui à
cette démission mais à condition d'âge
et des réformes institutionnelles et
deuxièmement il a promis un gouvernement
de coalition depuis tantôt un an mais ce
gouvernement a de cette formation du
gouvernement a du plomb dans l aile en
lui dire puisque
le président de la république à chaque
fois qu'il ouvre le dialogue
de notre côté il ferme les portes à ce
dialogue
jacques naisy merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
politologue à l'université des antilles
merci beaucoup